how can I see these guys on the inside
as human beings I can understand how
you're just reduced to something that
was a mistake life is not a straight
line and it's amazed there's a larger
story at play about resistance that's
what the boys left us with right resist
[Music]
one of our Central questions is are we
truly free when our brothers and sisters
are not free what happens to a Dream
Deferred yeah more black people
independent entries across this nation
than there were black people enslaved
before the Civil War and I've never done
anything like this before so for me to
walk in man and digest the scripture
they gave me was challenging for me I
have this history of legacy and about
Humanity when we came together we could
move a mountain yeah
this has been a unique tree because we
bring a lot of the incarcerated people
front and center we really really get to
meet them just real life human beings
our students are future scientists this
semester they're working with bee
colonies and understanding how bees help
the Earth I really just love like the
idea of these they're really interesting
juxtaposition of young black men in that
environment you might say that they're
dangerous and bad but the planet needs
them they help the world be better bent
was a really great entry point to that
because they know him you're not just an
awful person you have layers and that
was really really important for me to
get through because I even did a scent
in jail when I was like their age I'm
very much into Redemption I mean I am
that so there's no way I wouldn't want
people to see that in these characters
you
are not your biggest mistake
that really means something go ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
the other amazing thing that happened is
that they play a basketball game against
team comprised of these incarcerated
young men as we started doing rehearsals
I just kept saying but guys like what if
we just do it all in one shot Reggie
here is referencing the film on 1917
which is shot by one of the greatest DPS
ever I think they won the Oscar for that
film so I'm like yeah no we'll do that
no problem me oh yeah
easy I already do camera workouts but
the way you're subscribing I'm like I
guess I just need to like double my
workouts for the next month which I
started doing so I get around here from
the back yeah so you're down there when
that shot goes up all the background go
behind that tree over there please
sub just holding the camera up and it
was really you know technically just an
amazing cinematic feat that we're able
to pull that off
as much as I like to say this is not
solely a basketball show basketball's
important really love this idea that
we'll have to get the audience at the
edge of the seat and want to leaning
forward hit him with the truth
wait
[Applause]